Speaker 1: Folks, it looks to me that California
Governor Gavin Newsom is running for president
in 2024.
California Governor Gavin Newsom was interviewed
by Fox, L.A. and Gavin Newsom comes out swinging
and points out exactly what I've been saying
about Democrats for a decade now.
Gavin Newsom says We shouldn't be playing
defense.
We should be playing offense.
Democrats must be ferocious.
Democrats must be ruthless.
This is exactly what I have been saying for
over a decade on this program.
I am not saying that Gavin Newsom is my preferred
politician, that I agree with him on every
issue that is the epitome of a progressive.
But this guy identifies the exact issue is
using the right language, is pointing out
exactly what I've been pointing out.
He's coming out swinging.
Take a look at this from his interview over
the weekend.
Speaker 2: You have to also recognize what
you're up against.
And right now, we're up against the ruthlessness
of a Republican Party.
And I say that not naively.
I don't say that.
I'm not just not a cheap shot.
You see what's happening to all the progress
we've made in the 21st century, all of the
rights that we in many ways have taken for
granted that have been afforded since the
sixties are being rolled back in real time.
This is a totally different moment, and we
have to wake up with a different mindset and
not just old mindset in terms of just a collaborative
mindset, a cup of tea, and everyone's going
to work together to get along.
Think ways to advance the collective cause.
And that's where the party needs to come in.
Democrats need the Democratic Party, not the
president, not a speaker, not an elected office.
Speaker 1: All right, guys.
He's pointing out the absurdity of thinking
you're going to have a cup of tea with the
modern Republican Party and figure things
out and hash things out with them.
He is exactly correct.
Speaker 2: The party, the infrastructure,
I think, has to organize with more ferocity
of focus, more determination to set the agenda,
set the course, and put the other party on
the defensive.
They are dominating the narrative.
The facts aren't on their side, but they're
dominating there.
And in this world right now, you dominate
the narrative.
You win.
And that's what I'm worried about and that's
what I'm expressing.
Speaker 1: So this is all part of his gubernatorial
campaign for reelection.
But he is doing a lot of different things
that suggest greater ambitions.
He is running ads in Florida saying, hey,
if you want to come to the place with real
freedom, leave Florida, come to California.
He's doing interviews in which he is addressing
the major issues facing structurally from
a PR perspective, from a messaging perspective,
facing the Democratic Party.
I'm not endorsing Gavin Newsom.
He's not even running.
He's not the most progressive.
But this is a guy who could be president now
if he ran the smear campaign would be brutal,
but it would also be pretty toothless.
I mean, okay.
Stuff about his dating history.
You know, he was once married to kimberly
guilfoyle now who is now married to Donald
Trump Jr.
That's weird.
That doesn't that that's you know, it makes
it makes me question someone's choices, that's
for sure.
He had this dinner at the expensive restaurant,
the French Laundry, during COVID, when you
weren't supposed to be doing that.
That was wrong.
And he's going to get he's going to get hit
with that.
But they are potentially going to expose themselves
if they have to run against Newsom, because
from what's known, at least right now, the
criticisms and attacks on him would be brutal
but also quite toothless.
And Gavin Newsom is 100% correct here.
They have to be playing defense.
They're the ones who are out of step with
the views of the American people.
Why is it that the left is constantly playing
defense?
They are the ones who are proposing policy
that would be disastrous for millions of Americans,
whether it's on health care, whether it's
getting rid of Roe v Wade, whatever the case
is.
He's getting it and he is speaking about it
in a way that I'm not really hearing anybody
else talk about it right now.
So not endorsing anyone.
It's very interesting that he has got this
messaging down pat because this is the right
messaging.
And by the way, this messaging is much more
relevant on the national stage when you think,
okay, California.
California has large geographic areas that
are conservative, but from a population standpoint,
California is not conservative.
And when he talks about the strategy and tactics
that are required against this Republican
Party, it's fine to keep it in mind if you're
running for governor in California, but really
it's relevant nationally.
So this is super interesting.
We'll have this interview on our Instagram
at David Pakman show.
Check it out.
Tell me what you think.
I'm liking what
I'm hearing